You know, one thing I wanted to mention,
and I'm gonna use my hands,
'cause that's something people
do sometimes on television.
And these days you need to remind yourself
that this is being televised.
(claps hands)
One thing I wanted to mention,
my Conan Without Borders travel specials
are now streaming on HBO Max.
I really love doing these specials.
I visit places like Australia,
Greenland, Japan, Armenia.
Here's a clip from my trip to Ghana.
No, no passion for for me. (chuckles)
No, no, oh what's that?
If I eat the passion fruit, I'll get--
Get a lot of passion?
Yes.
If I eat the passion fruit,
my wife will be happy.
Very happy--
Because I'll have the energy.
Yes. Round, round, round
everyplace, every corner.
Yeah? Oh a chase?
I don't chase my wife around corners.
No, but it'll be good for me.
Yes you can even carry her like this woo!
Oh I can carry my wife
if I eat the passion?
I want passion fruit.
I want all of them.
If you eat passion you
get a good sexy night.
A good sexy night?
Yes!
Ha!
I've been buying pills through the mail.
No.
(Conan laughing suggestively)
Whoh!
Whoh yeah!
This is what I do?
No, no, no--
(audience roars)
You eat it.
Oh you eat it.
It's a lot of fun, so
make sure to check out
Conan Without Borders now,
on HBO Max.